i can speak to the bishop of dover rose
hudson wilkin
good morning bishop thank you
for joining us i know it's uh it's a
it's one of the busiest working days of
the year for you
good morning and i i'm in senate because
i'm just about ready to do a
confirmation service
well look um
what impact is covered having
on worship and worshipers this year
the the church has also borne the brunts
of
the impact of kovid
in terms of you know we had the church
locked and then
uh people have started coming back but
there is social distancing
and some people are still shielding and
it has impacted on the church
financially in the same way that it has
uh um impacted on business and and
ordinary people's lives
but you know we are god's church this
belongs to god
and so we are there to be a sign of hope
a sign of hope
for the community and the world around
us
is that sign of hope going to be open to
worshippers through christmas and new
year
i believe that we will be open uh
through christmas and going into the new
year you know we have learned what to do
and how to manage in this pandemic town
we've learned how to um make sure that
we keep safe
within our church it's something that we
didn't know
initially but we do know that now and we
will continue to make sure
that we are safe once we're in our
buildings
if the government were to say
we're not going to legislate but we
really would prefer people not to gather
what advice will you give to the priests
in your diocese
about
for example
christmas morning or christmas eve
services christmas morning
and indeed what in the old days we used
to call watch night services at the end
of the year
you know because as i said we now know
how to keep ourselves safe in terms of
washing you know we're going to have to
live with coronavirus
um it's not going to disappear and so we
can't just lock ourselves away but what
we can do
is that we can stay safe we wear our
mask we clean our hands regularly uh we
keep social distances we don't uh gather
unless we have to so i would want
the clergy in my diocese
to make the kind of decisions that says
we are keeping you safe when you come
through these doors i trust my clergy
and i am sure they will make the right
decision
you um
this is a politics show so of course
i've got to ask you something on that of
course not partisan you've probably seen
more of politics than
any uh cleric of any denomination having
been chaplain to the house of commons um
getting us through the pandemic does
depend on the authority of our leaders
um
do you have any fear that the scandals
and the revelations of the past year
have damaged uh the if you like the
moral authority of politicians
i think without a doubt we have to say
that the mixed messages
and the
do what i say and not as i do will
undoubtedly have
an impact
on
on on the nation going forward in terms
of how we respond
and so i would want to encourage our
politicians our political leaders
to actually
ensure that the messages that they're
giving to the wider community is a clear
message and also
that they follow the message themself
and and you know that they say this is
for all of us and not just for you and
and not ourselves we do our own thing
in a way you're echoing uh the ice
ritual canterbury's um message the other
day which is
an appeal for honesty
in politics
yes well you know it's not just honesty
in politics it's honestly in our lives
the need for us to live
lives that
is credible um for all to see
um so you know let's not it's let's not
beat beat the politicians alone
um it's for all of us uh to adhere to
um
bishop uh
i wouldn't do anything so vulgarous to
ask you to summarize uh your upcoming
sermon and
and of course some of our [ __ ]
some of our viewers won't share our face
but in 30 seconds or so um it's been a
tough year
what is the shepherd's message to the
flock
i think the the main message that i want
to share
is that
god loved for god so loved the world and
it is from that love
that god gave
so what we have is this generous god who
gives off himself to the world in his
son jesus christ who came to dwell with
us so that's my message let's practice
thank you
thank you bishop